anyways back to last night as you would
imagine i'm normally up for pretty much
anything in the bedroom
but i can't tell if what happened was
weird or sexy
wait close your eyes okay
[Music]
not that weird cold like a dead guy
you're reading into that
am i you have a really nice chest
thank you i'd love to crack it open and
get my hands all over your organs i
wonder how much your appendix weighs
oh it's inflamed all right
wait that's bad right yes
ew please tell me you ran out of there
no
for some reason i kind of started
getting into it
oh what do we have here a 34 year old
caucasian male
who is dead very dead
cause of death initial assessment blunt
force trauma
but what do i find when i probe a little
farther bruising around the neck
and ocean water in the lungs ooh how
long have you been dead body
four days gross bloating odors oh uh
24 hours perfect
here we go stop stop stop weird weird
weird
rosa what's your call weird or sexy
weird i knew it
but also kind of sexy
[Music]
you left without me you were late again
well i had to put on my undercover
minivan disguise
say hello to harvey norgenbloom cpa
recently divorced father of two with a
dark sexual secret
what's your cover angry captain okay
so you do not like my ensemble i'm just
concerned that you may find it hard to
pursue a criminal on foot
while wearing man's handles but the
sandals define harvey
he's a sandals guy blade runner tron
oh fievel goes west yes sir love that
little mouse
his journey the story of america i could
not agree more
rival papa
hey cause i'm not his mom put this
stupid braid in my hair
oh looks beautiful that's kind of cute
please have my children
it's him parking lot on flatbush and
vanderbilt in 15 minutes
let's go wait wait wait diaz looks like
a dirty criminal but you look like a cop
man you can't go over there like that
what'd you have in mind don't call it a
[Music]
comeback
i don't look like a cop now no you look
like a boys
easter album bird it's not a burner it's
cool
[Music]
i look like an idiot i didn't even have
time to lotion my forearms
ah it's so weird wearing rose's jacket
just piece barbed wire in the pocket
cool all right you have a visual one the
hostess stand
table for two please i'm so sorry
there's nothing available we're totally
booked up
oh no that's horrible tonight's a really
important night for us
johnny and i just got engaged and this
is where our first date was
oh yeah it would mean so much to dora
and me
i would have made a reservation but i
didn't know if she was gonna say yes
oh i love how nervous you were you
little goose
you are just so sweet together you know
i'm sure i can find room for two young
lovers
yeah we are lovers together
in bed okay peralta what are you doing
your nypd you're supposed to be hostages
supposed to be but we rose up and took
down the terrorists
that's right we're the bad guys now is
this some sort of
game to you does this sound like a game
i am a terrorist leader
my name is frances gruber my brother
hans died at nakatomi tower at the hands
of john mclean
also i'm related to jeremy irons from
the third one okay so it is a game
well i'm not playing drill's over
drill's over
hey boys yeah that's it got them wings
okay boom right there behind the bar
that's my dad's type
oh he's like some neat and clean real
tidy what
no blondes he likes blondes all right
here's the plan we're gonna go sit down
order a couple of drinks grab her
fingerprints off the glass she serves us
and then measure her wrist for handcuff
size
ready yeah oh ah crazy flight oh
hydraulics were loud
yeah ah bonjour bonjour uh
two whiskeys please chantelle thanks
say i'm looking for an old sky pal of
mine do you know roger peralta
yes yes i do how do you guys know
peralta i used to fly with him back in
oregon my name's captain spike masters
this is my co-pilot wanda cohen i drive
the plane when he sleeps i also take
care of hotel accommodations
where'd you guys say you flew in from
connected in akron took the old 78
niner on the windstream you know flight
stuff anyhow
could grab those two whiskeys please i
do not know who you are and i do not
think you are pilots
your suit doesn't even fit i had my
stomach stable
secure security examples
unhand us this is outrageous i demand to
speak with a commodore himself
there's no way we'll get her
fingerprints now oh really
french she cleaned the bar quite
thoroughly but this bottle is
filthy with her prince smirk that's why
you're the pilot and i'm the co-pilot
copy that wanda copy that
wanda going this
is awesome okay just so we're clear from
this point forward my call sign will be
death blade
and i'll be rump tum tugger no boyle no
characters from cats
dig deep think of something scary adopt
hitler
no you will be sidewinder
all right but i'm more scared of hitler
how about you captain what's your call
sign
i will be captain raymond holt yeah i
knew you wouldn't play ball and that is
why your call sign is wet blanket
sidewinder this is death play do you
copy sidewinder over
this is sidewinder death blade i read
you loud and clear over
do you have a 20 on wet blanket
sidewinder over
i do have a visual over all right look
captain
once said that we could have anything we
needed to solve this case yes but why
to catch a murderer who stole 21 million
dollars no it's so that when we do fail
it'll be that much more spectacular
if we don't get deangelo my career is
over but
if we do catch him your career will
really
take off chopper fun so you guys are
rich europeans looking about shelby
i'll make the introductions wait we
can't just be europeans what country are
we from what languages do you speak
french spanish some portuguese
obviously greek enough flemish to get by
tight what about you peralta
um i can do a pretty good italian accent
you think you could milk me
so you're just doing de niro from meet
the parents i don't know am i
it's a terrible dinero i don't know this
is daenerys i think it's pretty good
pretty good we'll just make you america
okay griff
hey doug judy hey what can i do for you
hey did my brother stop by i heard he
jacked some nice cars and i might have a
buyer this is maxine dubois
international millionaire who's you he
doesn't speak any english this is his
lawyer carl mangerson hey i'm a lawyer
maxine wants to buy shelby cobra here
george might have one yeah he just
dropped off a few cars but he didn't say
anything about no cobra
i mostly deal with scrap and crap you
know
[ __ ] is everything all right here
maxine you're speaking good english
that's just a few phrases he picked up
from movies and such
he's disappointed he really wanted that
cobra you know the french
so passionate even their skunks pepe le
pew it doesn't matter i'm a lawyer no
further comments
do you know what george is maybe i could
do business with him myself
gertie uh that was french for
i gotta make a phone call he's gotta
make a phone call
frenchman's you can't bring them
anywhere
according to the community center
calendar amateur ballroom dancing
competition
ah okay i know how we're gonna blend in
don't say thrift store thrift store
[Music]
he's been here for years watching
learning waiting
his code name fuzzy cuddle bear
he's an anacam ah you got lucky
no i got here five minutes before you
and figured that in this gigantic
electronic store there had to be at
least one working camera
oh hi bad guys you did it fuzzy you
busted them
it's time to come home i'm not sure if i
can
i've been undercover so long i've
forgotten who i am
i have seen terrible things i haven't
known the touch of a woman in many
wounds
you